Mm,
when we started the Tribeca film
festival,
which we announced in 2001 right after
nine slash 11,
uh,
to really bring people back to our
neighborhood.
Our goal was to just bring as many
people back downtown is possible.
When we announced the first film
festival,
we asked Nelson Mandela to come and
speak.
Our city had been devastated.
Our country has been devastated by nine
slash 11.
And as filmmakers we didn't know what to
do other than literally to put on a show
and to try to give,
to try to give our neighborhood a new
memory,
to try to give New York a new memory and
you just couldn't go like start running
movies.
So men Mandela came and he talked about
when he was in Robben Island,
when he was in prison,
that the one night that he and his
jailers all looked forward to was movie
night.
It's when they could come together and
they could laugh about the same thing.
They could cry about the same thing.
And they were,
they were one.
It was finding their similarities,
finding what was human about each of
them.
And no matter what side of the door
either one was going to end up at,
at the end of the night.
And I always think back to that and the
sense of community of coming together as
community to watch something is actually
extraordinary.
When you look at the nea in potential
cuts to the nea and you look at what
would happen to pbs,
uh,
it's criminal,
okay.
The arts reflect to a country what a
country is.
The arts reflect who we are as a people
and to lose that is losing part of our,
our soul.
You know,
the nea has been,
you know,
there've been other administrations that
have tried to cut the nea before,
uh,
but it's such a small amount in the
budget.
And it is again,
a reflection of,
of,
of who we are as a people and no matter
where you are in the ecosystem of being
a filmmaker,
a producer and actor,
it is always hard to get your project.
Maybe it is,
you know,
sometimes it happens very quickly,
but for the most part,
um,
it's never easy will artists get by
while we find a way to make work.
Yes.
But when I looked and I talked to a,
my friend will be Goldberg.
Some of her early work was funded by the
NEA.
Uh,
there is a wonderful piece on youtube of
Mr Rogers talking to Senator John Lopez
story explaining what he did as Mr
Rogers on pbs and it's just so charming
to listen to that and you're going,
how can you cut that?
One of the things is that our best,
our best export becomes our,
our shows or movies or entertainment.
And um,
I remember reading a piece after,
um,
I think it was nick kristoff writing
about how when they first went into
Afghanistan and,
uh,
you know,
in the,
in the nineties and people were digging
up their old vcrs after the Taliban had
left.
At that time,
there were digging,
going into the backyard,
digging up vrs and they were coming with
their,
you know,
dirty,
old brs that they had buried.
And um,
and the titanic and cassettes at the
titanic,
I mean,
they,
they love our love,
our movies.
They don't always love us,
but movies do remain a movie.
And I,
I,
I mean,
stories.
Our stories become most,
uh,
valuable,
exports.